on the day before Halloween I wrote this
song called um in the absence of
Christmas and I was gonna upload it on
Halloween because it's Halloween themed
but on the day of Halloween when I was
going to record it I got ill I got a
really bad cold and I couldn't sing but
I really really liked the song and I
don't want to have to like wait until
next Halloween to upload it because I'll
probably have lost interest in it by
then so if you don't mind even though
it's quite a bit after Halloween I'm
gonna play it for you today
I recorded all of this last night so
please ignore the fact that the lighting
and my clothes are going to change right
now
sitting in the living room staring at
the decorations feel so out of place in
this house sucking on a toffee apple
munching on some pumpkin pie seems so
out of place in his mouth such King Kong
who is busy eats a tangerines and clean
his palace someone get that man a mince
pie before he starts grinding down
merrily on high
Santa Claus - for Halloween
what did Santa Claus do for Halloween
trick-or-treaters come and knock here on
st. Nicholas's door but he ain't got no
candy for the trick-or-treaters getting
angry throwing eggs at Santa's still all
but he tells them they'll be sorry come
December 24 this holiday in makes no
sense no gold no butter presence baby
Jesus will be taking offense
Santa slouching by the fire in his
jovial attire he collapses to
knees would somebody help me please
so what did Santa Claus do for Halloween
what did Santa Claus do for hello
and he likes a jack-o'-lantern and he
throws it in the road and those kids
they run a screaming as the Lanson does
explode but the parents of those kiddies
photo sent to the ground and now say
Nick is quite surrounded and Halloween
is safe and sound
Oh what this Santa Claus do for
Halloween
what does Santa Claus do for Halloween
Oh what does Santa Claus do the
Halloween Oh
what does Santa Claus do for Halloween
sorry just answer a few questions that I
know will come up in the comments this
is called a melodica and it's like a
flute keyboard the reason I was wearing
headphones for the whole thing is
because I had to listen to the other
parts so I could like play them over
each other and also um I was looking at
the comments on my last video it seems
like a few people still don't know why I
shaved my hair off me and my friend Alex
Polk shaved off her hair live on the
internet to raise money for charity
we raised five thousand pounds for
cancer research UK which is about ten
thousand dollars so you're not allowed
to get angry at me for having their hair
because I did it for charity okay please
don't get angry at me sorry I need to
tell you actually my friend Jazza also
known as rhyming with oranges said that
if we manage to raise four thousand
pounds then he would shave off his hair
as well and we roast five thousand
pounds so obviously you had to so if you
have a look down there in the sidebar
then you can watch a video of Jasmin
getting his hair shaved off um that is
all ah good bye